el bayern munich sin falta se clasificó
a la final de la liga de campeones- lo
hizo en la noche de este miércoles aquí
en lisboa ante el olympique lyon el
equipo francés que perdió 3 goles por 0
y eso que el partido comenzó complicado
para los bávaros sobre todo los primeros
diez minutos con dos ocasiones claras de
gol desperdiciadas por los de lyon una
por memphis depay y otra por toco ecam y
bayern de múnich pues ellos no pierdan
la oportunidad en el minuto 18 apareció
en abril para abrir el marcador con un
zurdazo fantástico luego marcó un
segundo gol en el minuto 33 los de lyon
se fueron quedando sin ideas con muy
pocos recursos también en el segundo
tiempo los franceses trataron de salir
con un poquito más de fuerzas un poquito
más de ideas de juego y sin embargo eso
no fue suficiente el bayern cerró la
victoria ya en el minuto 88 gracias a un
cabezazo de lewandowski que terminó el
fondo de la red
de antonia lópez así que ahora la final
que se disputará este domingo aquí en
lisboa está para alquilar balcón
tendríamos por un lado al país sandra
man con neymar y maría y por
aparte tendremos a miller o no bueno
todas las estrellas del fútbol y por
supuesto por los bávaros parten como
grandes favoritos para ganar esta liga
de campeones sería su sexta corona
europea